[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight former CIA director John
Brennan has proven to be many things he
is dishonest having lied to the American
people multiple times while working as
director of the CIA he's irresponsible
he's accused his political opponents of
treason a death-penalty offense without
offering any evidence at all
but above all Brennan is vocal for the
past year he has shouted his views on
every possible political topic as is his
right well giving his opinion is
literally his job now actually he's a
cable news pundit yesterday the Trump
administration finally revoked his
security clearance
now why was John Brennan able to keep
his top secret clearance after leaving
government in the first place do other
MSNBC contributors have security
clearances if so what national interest
is served by that and how did somebody
so obviously limited intellectually get
to be CIA director in the first place
those are all valid questions no one
left even bothered to try to explain any
of those things and said they started
yelling about how Brennan's rights were
being violated
he knows the Russian collusion angle and
that's what Trump is trying to silence
next Sounion type practices of trying to
silence anyone who's willing to
criticize this president the larger
implication here is the Jeopardy to our
first our First Amendment rights and by
extension others here that the First
Amendment because you really don't have
freedom of speech unless you also have a
top-secret government security clearance
Brennan of course agreed with that he
wrote a piece claiming that Trump
revoked his clearance quote to try to
silence anyone who would dare challenge
him where was Brennan's essay about
being silenced published well in the New
York Times a newspaper with three
million subscribers and that ladies and
gentlemen is what it looks like to be
muzzled Senator Richard Blumenthal of
Connecticut who not only is a fake war
hero but also a graduate of Yale Law
School argued that Brennan somehow has a
constitutional right to a security
clearance
notice how Blumenthal keeps a straight
face as he says this watch it is not
only an abuse of power it is illegal
and the founders of our great nation
decided on the first amendment it was
because the King of England would
retaliate against his critics and he has
the authority to do a lot of things but
not in a way that violates the law hmm
thanks for the lesson on the law senator
so here's the takeaway John Brennan has
a constitutional right to a federal
security clearance though he does not
work for the federal government you do
not have that right neither do i or
anyone you know only John Brennan has
that right because he resides in a
special class of elites that you are
obligated to obey and by the way if you
disagree with any of that you are a
monster you are on the side of
bloodthirsty dictators like Stalin and
Pol Pot watch as more dumb people talk
what we're seeing today is this is what
dictators do this is a dictatorial
exercise of power that should frighten
it's a clear abuse of power and it's a
mark of an authoritarian dictator this
is a striking move towards
authoritarianism you know this is what
dictators do they shut down the press
and shut down dissent they jail their
opponents so it was a dictator what that
settle in for a minute if Trump is a
dictator he may be the single most
incompetent dictator in world history
for example he lets all these morons go
in cable television and accuse him of
crimes but doesn't do anything about it
they keep talking somebody better alert
the secret police but wait the secret
police are busy right now they're
watching MSNBC and nodding along in
agreement
it's that kind of dictatorship a looser
more Mediterranean version where no one
actually gets repressed of course if
you're looking for a more germanic style
of authoritarianism we have that too in
the United States but it's not in the
White House it's in Silicon Valley which
is happy to prevent you from expressing
your views in public if they disagree
with those views
that's everywhere these days and yet
amazingly somehow the champions of
speech you just watched first of I'm an
absolutist like senator Blumenthal who
learned the value of the Constitution
while pretending to serve in Vietnam
haven't noticed it's odd isn't it